an eventful morning for a clark clark  county elementary school teacher juliana  erdobay  she joined a virtual call and was  surprised with the 2021 nevada teacher  of the year award there she is getting  in there she's pretty shocked  urdubay teaches at brooker elementary  school she's recognized for being an  advocate for children and rigorous  family engagement programs  i'm obviously very touched and i'm  grateful  you know this is the year that we have  to represent teachers  and do it with love and with a smile and  so  i promise to do that to the best of my  abilities  um congratulations to juliana there  double the usual number of teachers  applied for the award  erta bay will represent teachers across  the state and attend national  professional development events as part  of her award